bentornati e ben trovati a una nuova
puntata di cucina imputate oggi io
voglio fare un esperimento alchemico
munire due elementi che non si sono mai
visti insieme da una parte un elemento
come la paura per gli anni di palle
famose quella che è in mano agli
imperatori ai nei dipinti o nelle stato
che rappresenta il loro potere temporale
pensiamo alla palla da calcio lo sport
più amato pensiamo importantissime alle
palle di rocco siffredi chi non le
conosce e l'altro elemento è il
formaggio
pensiamo alla bontà non lo so della
nostra cacio e pepe
pensiamo alle funghi o parigine ma
ancora una volta pensiamo all
inconfondibile sapore delle palle di
rocco siffredi che in questa puntata di
cui si era buttata uniremo il potere
degli imperatori alla tradizione romana
oggi uniremo lo sport a parigi oggi
soprattutto uniremo le palle di rocco
siffredi alle palle di rocco siffredi
perché facciamo delle palle al formaggio
iniziamo ben tornata in una puntata di
cucina buttata iniziamo subito quella di
oggi non sarà una ricetta come quelle
che abbiamo già fatto oggi facciamo una
cosa che volevo fare da un sacco di
tempo ma da tanto tanto tanto tanto
aiutati nel dire tanto tempo abbiamo
sempre detto facciamo noi per
un'occasione speciale un'occasione
speciale quando faremo la nuova cucina
quando avremo l'ufficio e tutto quanto è
certo punto ci siamo detti non riusciamo
ad aspettare dobbiamo capire se questa
cosa funziona oppure no quella doveste
replicare questa ricetta vi prego datemi
su instagram puglia è uscita perché è
sempre molto bello vedere quello che
state facendo soprattutto ringrazio
tutte quante le persone che hanno fatto
che la spugna commestibile e ho un
rispetto per voi infinito e sempiterno
comunque oggi faremo delle palline di
formaggio avete presente le patatine
no certo passiamo agli ingredienti
per fare le palle di formaggio avremo
bisogno di 90 grammi di preparato per
pure a 50 grammi di fecola di patate 30
g di parmigiano reggiano 750 g di acqua
500 meno di 500 ma chi sei come fanno i
350 c'è una tacca 750 detto quelli sono
meno di 500 no no 350 mezzo cucchiaino
di lievito di birra e 7 grammi di sale
per fare questa ricetta utilizzeremo un
raro tortello tra in un modo per cui io
ti vorrei licenziare ora per fare questa
ricetta di un robot da cucina perché
perché dovremmo tritare finemente tutto
quanto quindi raccontare quello che
facciamo solitamente varieremo oggi
ognuno di noi possiede una casa se non
lo possedete compravo compra vero o
utilizzate magari un frullatore anche
immersione sono che potrebbe dovrebbe
fare fateci sapere se ti funziona
noi per essere sicuri per fare una
ricetta che almeno ci venga anche perché
io le patatine col formaggio le amo
utilizzerò il robot da cucina perché ha
fatto tre ruoli sul cosa non perché così
posso farmi serve ogni tanto per prima
cosa buttiamo il parmigiano la fecola di
patate il preparato per pure 7 grammi di
sale
secondo me questi sono sette grande non
hai misurati mezzo cucchiaio di lievito
viaggio mezzo cucchiaio chiude il
boccalone e far andare un pochino gli
ingredienti secchi a vuoto in modo da
sminuzzarle e unirli perbene ma che
bisogna fare delle note sono mio perché
le polveri sono diverse tra di loro è
come dire che un gigante dica che gli
umani sono tutti quanti uguali to
chiaramente se diverso da me oddio conto
pur maggio lo so me che ogni sera
benissimo per aggiungere un po di pepe
come un pochino se fossero caccia e pose
e dei piedi quindi vediamo proprio 23
qua finito con un po di pepe ci stanno
bene riuscendo a quelle formaggio xi ma
un po troppo schiacciato tra cui air one
con via bene ora va beh non lo
giudichiamo subito io ho fatto un botto
di errori nella mia vita un giorno c'era
enrico sul ciglio di un precipizio e
l'ho trattenuto adesso attiviamo di
nuovo
attiviamo di nuovo le lame e questa
volta versiamo cambiare uno strappo ap
lo buono anzi la cucina anche pazienza
sarà per questo e se incapace in cucina
io se non in cui tu sei fare quattro
piatti gianmarco e basta non lo puoi
dire una cucina bella carne io so che
facciamo sfida la sfida di cucina io e
te guarda come ha paura è decide il
pubblico votante noi su cosa dovremmo
fare una sfida di cucina e e gianmarco
come la struttura resta il commento con
più like sarà quello che noi faremo
esatto abbiate inventiva ragazzi e lo
smer diamo per cento questo è il
risultato ragazza sembra buono io lo
vorrei addensare leggermente sì una
bottarga perché non mi se
mi sembra troppo liquido mente invece
per riuscire a fare delle palline quindi
dovrebbe essere leggermente più asciutto
scusate se dico una cosa saggia quindi
io un po parmigiano ma tutti gli
ingredienti tutte le dosi sono entrare
da un altro pochino sì le evito il
tremendo
no no no devi stare situare si erigono
basta che ti stai zitto
oppure ne vogliono di marmo sono tipo le
nevi su chiari stai zitto cioè come dato
proprio il gusto peggiore di tutti che è
il tipo meno e per ha aggiunto di
calcolare la migliore aggiungiamo un po
di pure 86 minimo linea una banda di pg
[Risate]
gianmarco zara capacità di afferrare le
cose ci siamo incrociati e miglio il
meglio io sono numerosi e giammarco
la cosa come simile più dura che io
abbia mai mangiato
secondo me sono buonissime poteva
evitare di mangiarvi le mie pupo che
stima buttata in silenzio è questo turno
io vorrei una vita il silenzio però
certo potreste arrivi merano quell'alta
è che dovevo fare
sul podio riprendi a rigori premi di
aspettare un attimo all ieri convenuto
malissimo ma dà la stessa cosa ha detto
mamma quando ha partorito premuto
malissimo ma se facciamo un pallone
norme la fridge e guarda la pasta in
presente mi scusi lo scroto a questa già
detta una parola del nord come anche ma
c'è anche a fare pallina in giornata
della nostra più grossa fa delle palline
vada più grosso da e basta noi che che è
più povera quella più grossa decade
stava alla ecco un'altra facciamo le
sette stelle di hokuto
secondo me non c'è una regola su come
farla cioè uno deve fare un po come
quelle in tutto questo è fatto solo due
pallini levarci un'altra bellini delle
palline di ricorsi che loro sono così il
radio gigante era mia fiero e così
rilassante
non dobbiamo mai interrompere il flusso
ok è un'importante ragguaglio secondo me
devono devono essere grandi perversione
cavallo abbiamo un moncherino salva se
li lasci troppo da un lato di anton fury
un certo devi buttare e girare in modo
che si fanno se le tieni sono da un lato
si bloccano e poi da sopra incomincia a
uscire tutto quanto era già
come stai ragazzi vi è piaciuta la
puntata di gianluigi parte che il pesto
air buonissimo ma non lo so se non l'ha
assaggiato no ma sembra comunque se
volete recuperare la puntata di
gianluigi di cucina cliccate qua su che
vi lascio il link e fatemi sapere se ne
vorreste vedere altri video enrico
errico che c'è cos'è questo cos'è
qualità che si sono unite ha ridico
c'è già siamo pronti nell'assaggio
assaggio di già pensate teniamo la luce
dietro
mammamia giammarco allora qua sotto
cipullo se sentite dei versi sappiate
che il mio cane aspetto
alcune sono molto carine altre sono
deformi non bellissima ma sono molto
carine non ricordano le palline al
formaggio dritta forma di a chieti è
nato a carini belle nel senso non sono
pagati dal formaggio bocciate da quel
punto di vista ma palette fitte
deliziose devo dire non hanno il
classico colore della pallina al
formaggio che ha detto quelli che sono
venute bene secondo me sono 18 una cosa
così quale sono venute male sono due
affetto gli hanno un bel tom 6 globale
sette e mezzo dai l'odore ragazzi c'è un
piccolo problema ma qualsiasi cosa
fritta secondo me ha un odore che già
prendi più 2 fritta intensa ha un odore
di fritto intenso quindi per me il
profumo più buono che esista non fa per
niente di patata mi aspettavo qualcosa
di più speziato visto quello che ci
abbiamo messo come qualsiasi freddo non
s'è un po deludente motore di base
secondo me sei più il bonus qui 28
quindi sono e l'odore 568 all'odore di
questo piatto però se deve essere legato
a quel concetto non cerchiamo proprio
non convincente però sufficiente seri e
mezzo dai sempre i miei molti
confusionarie
a taggia
questa era po cruda il formaggio ci sei
bevuto ma invece sta roba via ce l'ho
fatta io con le mie squisite mani e si
sente che c'è l'amore appena stagionata
tantissima sono un grande fan delle
patate in generale interna in buonissima
per una crocchetta queste sono bacchette
abbiamo avviato il piatto allora serie
di mente le patatine quelle classiche
tonde scordare le non c'entra niente con
la pallina al formaggio di riferimento
non avevamo in rocchetta o come
crocchetta mi piace il sapore darei
schiphol 74 globalmente il sapore anche
buono do un sei e mezzo come patatina
tondar formato da io l'ho levato come se
fossero concrete sette e mezzo avrei
voluto assaggiare il pene che purtroppo
è stato sottratto per quanto sei
disposto a pagare in un ristorante di e
molto probabilmente senza scuse
sbagliato l'ordine procede riportate
indietro ed armi e cosa dire formaggio
grazie al fatto di 5 euro 5 euro una
boutade est e crocchette venduta una
patatina non mi convince vera oppure
bello abbondante verso 5 euro non
pagherei parola carbonia un po bruciata
per me però se vi piacciono crocchette
cioè bella per poi queste qui presenti
all'altra non era fisicamente
i miei ragazzi siamo neanche la piedi
questo video se vi è piaciuto quello che
abbiamo fatto metteteci un bel pollice
in su fateci sapere che cosa ti
piacerebbe vedere su questo canale che
mi raccomando su instagram taggate mi
qualora si dovesse fare queste ricette
io ogni tanto vi riposo era sempre molto
divertente alle regole che fate ma allo
stesso tempo scrivetemi nei messaggi
privati cosa ti piacerebbe vedere su
questo canale magari rimandate dei link
di ricette assurde o cose un pochino
strane ne stanno arrivando un sacco e
sappiate che li stiamo già passando al
vaglio detto ciò iscrivetevi attive
della campanellina perché siete delle
persone brave noi ci vediamo giovedì
prossimo
ciao